E aí
[Música]
e no dia trinta de Janeiro de 1997 os
membros do culto religioso heaven's
Gates pagaram mais de 3.600 dólares por
um telescópio super sofisticado para
enxergar algo que eles esperavam há mais
de 20 anos e 97 o cometa halebop passava
a próxima terra e o líder do culto
acreditava que colada na cauda dele
viajava uma nave espacial queria coletar
as almas dos membros do grupo e
transformá-los em seres mais evoluídos
o cruzamento no dia sete de Fevereiro os
membros do culto voltaram uma loja para
devolver o telescópio pedir um reembolso
quando a gerente do estabelecimento
perguntou o motivo da devolução um dos
membros disse que o telescópio tava com
defeito pois eles conseguiram enxergar o
cometa perfeitamente mas não a nave
espacial que tava atrás dele assim como
você eu ri na primeira vez que escutei
essa história até perceber que eu também
colocava a culpa no telescópio quando
enxergava aquilo que eu queria
e infelizmente muitos de Nós preferimos
não ver para crer
assim que o Brasil entrou em liquidação
de vida pandemia eu achava que tudo não
passava em algum tipo de conspiração
alguma armação da mídia um golpe dos
líderes mundiais no esquema das
companhias farmacêuticas
e a casa discurso de políticos ou
empresários execrando as medidas Loki
dão ou minimizando a Fatalidade do vírus
que eu vibrava
Ah e por incrível que pareça o que me
fez repensar esse posicionamento foi uma
inacreditável
maratona de las ao assistir algum dos
meus cientistas favoritos para o meu
choque nenhum deles falava que o
coronavírus era algum tipo de armação
vírus fabricado uma conspiração criada
pela mídia e eu me perguntava como é que
eles enxergavam que tudo aquilo não
passava de um golpe
alguns dias mais tarde depois ele
dezenas de artigos científicos eu
descobri que o cego nessa história que
era eu
é assim que nos membros do heaven's Gate
eu queria enxergar aquilo que era
conveniente para mim aquilo que eu
encontro dos Meus interesses
e como professor e autor grande parte da
minha renda vende palestras presenciais
algo que não iria mais acontecer se as
pessoas fossem obrigadas a ficar em casa
Eu também sou consultor em viagem O país
inteiro para atender empresas
e nos negócios iriam ruim se o look Down
Viesse a ser algo de longo prazo a
situação mais conveniente para mim era
acreditar que o vírus era inofensivo que
a mídia tava sendo o sensacionalista
para vender anúncios ou que um grupo é
fácil de empresários poderosos Tá
armando alguma coisa para ter lucro há
quase duas décadas eu estudo vieses
comportamentais de um nunca imaginei que
poderia ser vítima deles Com tamanha
facilidade uma das primeiras lições que
eu perdi uma pandemia foi ele que não
importo com Inteligente você é
e você pode ser enganado o fenômeno que
me fisgou da mesma forma que fez com os
membros do heaven's Gates é conhecido
pelos cientistas como dissonância
cognitiva que demonstra que nós tendemos
a descartar as evidências contrárias Às
nossas crianças mesmo quando isso coloca
as nossas vidas em risco a dissonância
cognitiva desconforto causado como somos
expostos a duas cognições conflitantes a
comissão eu acredito que uma nave
espacial viajando atrás do Cometa vai
coletar a minha alma e me transformar em
um ser mais evoluído é conflitante uma
outra comissão eu comprei o telescópio
procurei a nave espacial mas só
enxerguei o cometa
e para reduzir seu desconforto e passar
se sentir bem de novo a pessoa tem duas
opções ela deixa ele acreditar no culto
é um ela tenta convencer assim mesmo de
que sua crença está correta descartando
qualquer evidência contrária por
telescópio tava com defeito
e quando a gente possui uma crença
profundamente enraizada toda vez que
essa criança é colocada em xeque o
caminho mais confortante sempre é
colocar culpa no telescópio e manter a
nossa criança vida
principalmente quando sentimos que a
imagem que queremos construir em nós
mesmos como pessoas inteligentes
honestas e Racionais está sendo ameaçada
ninguém gosta de descobrir tá errado por
isso que nós somos respostas e
informações que contrariam as nossas
crenças além de fabricarmos todos os
tipos de justificativa a gente ainda
Procura por informações e opiniões que
confirmam que estamos certos
raramente procuramos informações que
podem mostrar que estamos errados
e esse comportamento é conhecido como
viés da confirmação
na década de 70 os cientistas o
Washington state University fizeram
estudo onde os participantes favoráveis
e contrários à liberação da maconha
deveriam escutar com fones de ouvido
mensagens que defendiam a legalização da
substância em algumas mensagens eram
fortes e difíceis de refutar enquanto
outras eram bobas fáceis de se vencer o
truque Necessito não foi que eu senti
essas colocar um ruído nos fones que
atrapalhava a audição das pessoas para
acabar com o líder é só apertar um botão
que cancelar o barulho por 5 segundos e
tem que será que aconteceu
e os favoráveis à liberação da maconha
quase não apertar um botão quando vi o
argumentos fracos já os contrários não
apertavam um botão quando eram
apresentar os argumentos fortes
além de não ver para crer o ser humano
também prefere não escutar para crer
e esse estudo explica também porque
confiança na mídia está em declínio Por
que todos os dias a mídia apresenta
notícias contrárias aos nossos mais
profundos desejos
notícias que colocam a nossa autoimagem
como inteligentes e bons esses dois em
questionamento por isso que muitos
preferem receber apenas informações
totalmente imparciais aquelas vindas de
fontes extremamente confiáveis os
políticos
vale tudo para manter o nosso ego
elevado para se livrar da sensação
desconfortável de termos votado alguém
desonesto ou incompetente o ser humano
tem obsessão por sempre dar certo as
pessoas usam a hashtag nada Carinhoso
para medir aqui no Brasil mas um estudo
feito por cientistas da Stanford mostra
que o lixo provavelmente está em outro
lugar escondido nas mais profundas
estruturas bem aqui dentro
e na véspera das eleições Americanas de
1980 o cientista Robert volume descobriu
que Noventa e Seis por cento dos
eleitores de Ronald Reagan acreditavam
que a mídia favorecer o outro candidato
de me Carter enquanto 83 por cento dos
eleitores e cartas afirmavam que a mídia
favorecer Porém esse fenômeno é
conhecido como viés da mídia hostil e
nossa visão a mídia sempre favorece o
inimigo
centenas Estudos comprovam que o nosso
cérebro não é uma calculadora que
processa informações de forma neutra
analisando com igualdade os dois lados
de uma disputa e chegando a uma
conclusão precisa e muitas pessoas
afirmam que o ser humano é racional mas
na verdade somos racionalizadores nós
racionalizamos qualquer informação para
obter os resultados que queremos aqueles
que satisfazem o nosso ego nós não
assistimos a mesma notícia interpretamos
de forma que protege a nossa posição
e faça analisamos a corrupção do
candidato em que votamos Nada foi
provado contra ele racionalizamos os
anos que perdemos trabalhando em uma
empresa abusiva foi uma escola
racionalizamos as decisões erradas o
nosso político favorito é uma
perseguição da mídia
racionalizamos até derrota do time que
torcemos o juiz Era ladrão tudo para
proteger a mais elevada a imagem que
queremos projetar de nós mesmos
e o cientista político do Oeste da emory
University descobriu o álbum importante
sobre a nossa capacidade de racionalizar
o melhor sobre a falta dela
e quando escutamos dados contrários as
nossas crenças políticas as áreas o
nosso cérebro responsáveis pelo
raciocínio desligam
É sim o ser humano não ver para crer não
escuta para creme e também não pensa
para crer
apesar dessas falhas as continuamos
acreditamos que enxergamos o mundo
exatamente como ele é
algo que os cientistas nomearam como
Realismo ingênuo a ilusão de que somente
nós temos o super poder de ver o mundo
com precisão de forma Imparcial sem
nenhum tipo de viés e Assim ficamos
livres para dizer que aqueles que
enxergam o mundo de forma diferente da
nossa são malucos ou mal intencionados
bom e quando a gente tem envenenado por
esse pensamento algo ainda mais grave
acontece
o deixando e seguir em 3 2 1 cê já deve
ter visto isso nas redes sociais e um
nome Pode até ser recente Mas o
comportamento antigo a cultura do
cancelamento piora tudo pois esse
comportamento faz com que a gente se
certo é apenas de pessoas que comungam
das nossas opiniões
nos brindando totalmente a opiniões
contrárias o que protege ainda mais o
nosso égua
décadas estudos científicos demonstram
que uma pessoa sozinha não consegue
pensar em todas as razões pelas quais
sustenta uma crença
é mas quando ela se cerque de pessoas
com opiniões similares Ela escuta novos
argumentos que a fazem acreditar com
ainda mais fervor em seus pontos de
vista é assim que a polarização começa
ninguém gosta de ser visto como um
extremista mas é exatamente isso que nos
tornamos Quando cancelamos aqueles que
pensam diferente da gente de onde é que
a ciência se encaixa no meio dessa
confusão a ciência não pode se dar o
luxo de ver apenas um lado da história
um cientista por até ter um ponto de
vista mais diferente de todos nós ele
nunca pode buscar somente os dados que
confirmam que ele está certo
e a metodologia científica tem como
regra formulação de uma hipótese nula
onde o cientista é obrigado a levantar
informações para provar que fora está
errado e a ciência tem como objetivo A
Busca Pela verdade
doa quem doer
você pode até não gostar do resultado de
um artigo científico Mas isso não faz
dele uma mentira e assim como a mídia
nem sempre as descobertas científicas
satisfazem o nosso EGO na grande maioria
das vezes a ciência desafia a imagem que
queremos construir de nós mesmos como
seres Racionais e inteligentes do bem
imparciais e bons decisores respondo
Cruel mente que somos simplesmente
e umas
tragicamente no dia vinte e seis de
março de 1997
39 membros do heaven's Gate foram
encontrados mortos em uma mansão em San
Diego na Califórnia
vítimas de suicídio coletivo essas
pessoas preferiram manter suas crenças
intactas
descartando as evidências de que não
havia uma nave espacial atrás documento
e hoje em dia Muitas outras estão indo
por mesmo caminho e um momento onde até
há comprovações científicas são
refutadas em prol de posicionamentos
políticos
nesses últimos anos eu descobri que não
é porque eu vou tem algum candidato que
eu tenho dever de aceitar tudo o que ele
disso só para manter uma imagem positiva
sobre quem eu sou e eu entendi que
deixando de lado uma crença eu não perco
parte de quem eu sou
e nós jogamos as pessoas que mudam de
opinião como inconsistentes e fracas
mudar de ponto de vista encarado como um
pecado por muitos de nós
mas a verdade é que mudar de opinião é
um sinal que temos humildade para
aprender de que podemos ajustar as
nossas decisões de acordo com as novas
evidências ao invés de continuarmos com
teimosias perigosas
Errar é humano persistir no erro também
humano assim como é humano ter coragem
para assumir um erro e mudar de opinião
e a ciência não é perfeita mas ela é sem
dúvida o telescópio mais sofisticado que
existe aquele que mostra friamente as
nossas imperfeições
mas que também pode nos transformar
verdadeiramente em seres mais evoluídos
é muito obrigado e
G1